wouldn't you know it Shaq we just happen
to have a
message congratulations Shaquille on
retirement of your jersey with the
Orlando Magic of course this is your
number one fan saying congratulations to
you I can remember back when they called
your name Orlando Magic with the first
pick and they picked Shaquille O'Neal we
were also happy for you as well as
excited and I have to tell you you made
us all proud with all of that joy and
excitement you brought to the Orlando
Community this award and this
recognition is well deserved so we want
you to enjoy it we're so proud of you
and we pray that you continue to enjoy
life and don't ever forget the memories
God bless you my
son why is your mom so calm and cerebral
you're such an
ass